انفجار سد كخوفكا في اوكرانيا ستصل
تاثيراته الى ابعد من المحيط القريب فقط
وتقاذف الاتهامات طبعا بين الجانبين مستمر
الساد تم بناؤه باستخدام التربه المضغوطه
التي تعتبر طريقه لامتصاص
الانفجارات الشديده من هنا ظهرت فكره ان
التفجير تم من الداخل في الجانب الميداني
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني السابق اندريه
زاكورود نيوك لمجله ان اي هجوم اوكراني
محتمل عبر دهر اصبح الان مستحيلا فعليا
لماذا لانه على احد جانبي النهر مشاهدينا
يوجد خطر على محطه زابوريجيا للطاقه
النوويه التي يعتمد نظام التبريد فيها على
المياه المخزنه بسد كخوفكا والان ومع
انخفاض مستوى المياه فيه قد يؤدي ذلك الى
انهيار وحدوث كارثه نوويه لن تقتصر فقط
على اوروبا اذا انفجر السد ومهما كان
المتسبب بالتفجير فمن المرجح ان تتضرر
روسيا وتحديدا في شبه جزيره القرم التي
اقتطعتها موسكو من اوكرانيا قبل تسعه
اعوام تدمير السد يمكن ان يعرض للخطر
امدادات المياه العذبه لشبه جزيره القرن
والحديث هنا عن قناه شمال القرن تحديدا
التي تزود عبرها روسيا شبه الجزيره
بالمياه العذبه طبعا هذه القناه كانت توفر
حوالي
85% من مياه شبه جزيره القرم ومعظمها كان
يستخدم للزراعه ثم ايضا بمجالات الصناعه
والاستهلاك العام وسيطرت القوات الروسيه
على القناه في اليوم الاول من الحرب التي
انطلقت في فبراير من العام الماضي عندما
تقدمت مجموعات روسيه شمالا جزيره القرم
للسيطره على القناه
محللون قالوا لمجله نيويورك ان اغلاق
القناه او حتى خانق امدادات المياه في شبه
جزيره القرم كان من الخيارات القليله
المتاحه لدى اوكرانيا ويبدو الان ان
انفجار سد كخفقه قد يكون عاملا للضغط على
روسيا في شبه الجزيره رغم ذلك اضاف
المحللون ان الاولويه العسكريه للكرامل
تتركز على شبه جزيره القرم ومحاوله عدم
خسارتها
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات